في اواخر ستينات واوائل سبعينات القرن
العشرين انطلق برنامج ابولو نحو القمر
محملا باثني عشر رائد فضاء جميعهم من
الرجال السؤال هنا لماذا فقط من الرجال
قبل ان نتحدث عن الاجابه الخبر اليوم ان
امريكا تستعد لارسال اول امراه الى سطح
القمر وبعد عقود من وصول الرجل ستصل
المراه الى جارنا القمر على كل حال وفقا
لبيانات الامم المتحده فان النساء يشكلنا
احد 10% من رواد الفضاء ونحو 20% من القوى
العامله في قطاع الفضاء ونحو 30% من
الباحثين في المجال وبالرغم من الجهود
المبذوله لزياده عدد النساء في الفضاء الى
ان ارقام 2021 اظهرت انه من اصل الخمس 266
شخصا ذهبوا الى الفضاء اعتبارا من مارس 20
20 كانت 65 امراه منهم فقط
فلماذا هذه التفرقه الفضائيه الكبيره بين
الرجال والنساء
على كل حال بعيدا عن المشاعر سنتحدث علميا
هذه المره بين الفرق الكبير بين الرجال
والنساء في عالم الفضاء قد تكمن الاجابه
في القدره على تحمل مستويات عاليه من
الاشعاع في الفضاء بحسب ناسا فان النساء
تتاثرن باكثر من ضعف خطر الاصابه بالسرطان
الرئه مقارنه بالرجال عند تعرضهن للاشاعه
لنفس الفتره ووفقا لتقرير مرشور على موقع
لايف ساينس فان حدود حمايه رواد الفضاء من
خطر الاشاعه وضعت عام
1989 وهي تختلف اتباعا حسب العمر والجنس
وعلى عكس ما يعتقد الكثيرون فان الاكبر
سنا هو صاحب الحظ الاوفر للبقاء فتره اطول
في الفضاء ويترك لفتره اطول لتعرض للاشعه
السبب ان ما بقي من حياته اقل من رائد
الفضاء الشاب ومع ذلك في عام 2021 طالبه
وكاله ناسا بتغيير حد الاشعاع الوظيفي الى
600 م لجميع رواد الفضاء على النساء الاص
سنا كان متوسط لدرجه الخطر
[موسيقى]
المزيد ينضم الينا من القاهره دكتور
الاقليمي لتدريس علوم الفضاء بالامم
المتحده اهلا بك يا دكتور امريكا تستعد
لارسال الاول امراه الى القمر اهميه هذا
الحدث الذي طال انتظاره لماذا طال انتظاره
حتى اليوم
فريد
الاداره الامريكيه او اداره ناسا غيرت
رايها تماما في اختيار الجنس يعني ذكر او
انثى فعلا في الاول كان يقول المراه
بالاشعاع النهارده برنامج ارتميس اللي هو
هيطلع همم القمر وهو يعمل مستعمره قمريه
همم
بالعكس اختار همم 18 همم رائد فضاء من
ضمنهم تسعه نساء
اخذ 50% وبعدين حتى كلمه ارتي بالذي عباره
عن يعني هي منسوبه الى جهه القمر يعني ايه
واحده ست برده او واحده سيده يعني هي في
الاساطير الاغريقيه بيقولوا هذا الكلام
يعني فرق العالم غير همم نهب وتماما وناس
كده هتطلع ان شاء الله في 24 هيطلع رائده
فضاء همم واحد برده اخر او من سكان
الاصليين واعتقد دكتور علاء هل ستكون
المراه اقوى في رصد ما يجري في الفضاء
بحكم ان طبيعه النفس البشريه
للنساء اقوى في ادق التفاصيل مسح ودراسه
ما يجري بكامل تفاصيلها
وده حقيقي
احتمالا من الرجل يعني احنا لازم نعترف
بهذا يعني وطبعا للمؤشرات الجديده في
اختيار رائدات الفضاء لا النهارده اصبحوا
يمثلوا 50% بالظبط من الرجال وانا اعتقد
بقى يعني هما التي لم يقلينه عن فائده
الفضاء على اسمها ولكن اعتقد ان هي ان
نقول يعني لانها لها خبره كبيره جدا وبرده
حتى صحتها جيده جدا وهمم سنها مش كبير
وبالتالي انا اعتقد ان فعلا الناس هتختار
هذه السيده لانها اوريدي همم يعني هتطلع
في محطه الدوليه او طلعت وهتقعد خمس اشهر
فهم عارفين ان هي شديده البث ولا قدره
كبيره على التحمل وانا اعتقد بنسبه اكثر
من 90% ان فعلا
هي اللي هتكون همم
لكن هل بالفعل هي اكثر تاثر بها الاشعاعات
العاليه
لا الموضوع ده تغير على فكره يعني الموضوع
ده اتغير هو كان الاول فيه بعض المؤشرات
بتقول الكلام ده لكن ثبت خطاؤه وبالتالي
في برنامج ارتيميس اللي هو طلع ارض نسوان
طلع وفي لسته 2 وقرن 3 و4 و5 همم قالوا لا
الكلام دوت وبالتالي
نص عدد رواد الفضاء المرشحين لبرنامج
ارتميس من النساء فالفكره تغير تماما يعني
تغير تماما بشكل كبير يعني بس دكتور علاء
لكي نفهم اكثر يعني لا يوجد عائق بيولوجي
يمنع المراه من ان تذهب وتسافر في رحله
الى الفضاء لانه في السابق يعني عندما تمت
الاستعانه بالنساء سوء لنا اسئله تتعلق
ببيولوجيهنا باجسدهن كانت محرجه جدا و
غريبه
ما اعتقدش هو ايه اللي ما كانوش وافقوا ان
تروح تقعد خمس اشهر في الفضاء في ميعاد
الفضاء الدوليه لا الموضوع ده اتغير تماما
من كل حضرتك وانا كنت مع مجموعه من
العلماء من الناس وهم اصدقاء كان معانا
زملا في لجنه صدام حسين من الفضاء قالوا
الكلام ده اتغير وفعلا يعني عشان كده
اعلنوا ان في امراه هتطلع ومشكله وبس
واختاروا 50% من الواد الفضاء المخصصين
لمهمه ارتميس من النساء شكرا جزيلا لك من
القاهره حدثنا الدكتور رئيس المكتب
الاقليمي للتدريس علوم الفضاء بالامم
المتحده شكرا جزيلا دكتور